có người gọi thêm miệng đối vả sống mạnh trên biển.
Cô vực mình nú tình quan trị xuất hiện hơn tò đến rất tò.
Tại của bật biệt dưới lộn mưa từ một chăm mùa trong năm 2019,
là mừng nước sống sẽ pong dông khoảng 1 phẩy năm 2019,
nhiều cầu đập trang tại các sã hướng phung là bảo.
Bị ngập nước trị sết khi người và phương tiện không thể qua lại.
Tại sã hướng phung, nước dân gây gập kìm cầu đập trang soá má lại,
a rong và khu bực giống phung lâm soá má lại.
Tại sã lâu bảo một số cầu trang qua suy các trang soá trung
và khu bực thôn khai đã bị ngập cầu bộ.
Cầu trang thôn hà lệ tổ thử dân gập sâu khoảng 3 cm.
Tại sã tên lập nước cũng giăng tạm một số cầu trang đập trang và tuyên đường.
Đến chính giờ bà mi phút sáng nay ngày 1 chiến tạm trước khi nhận thiệt tại biển người bà nhà cửa.
Lừng bà chiến năng đang tăng cường cạnh giới tại các điểm gặp
giá sóa khu dân cơ có khu íc sạp lượng ngập lù tình.
Để chủ đọc xơ tạm khi cẩn thiết,
người dân được quaint cao khâm có vượt qua cầu trang ngâm trang
họ khu vượt có nước trải sát.